Jeffrey Runyon is coming to us through
Google+
he says if humans are ever going to
travel to Mars what are we going to eat
along the way food has a major
psychological aspect to it if people are
going to be under enormous stress in
close quarters for two years or plus two
plus years they're going to need more
than astronaut ice cream to keep them
going of course and there there's a hold
for this cicala there's an entire branch
of psychologists that are in the employ
of NASA at Houston yes that's the
Johnson Space Center in Houston whose
sole job is to worry about the mental
health of astronauts let's just get that
up front okay yes there is okay if
number one number two the about the food
I actually visited the kitchen the the
cosmic kitchen at NASA at Johnson and
you meet the chef who is making food
that can last 10 years without
refrigeration Wow I had a steak that had
been in a bin a packet on the shelf for
five years unrefrigerated but so some
foods they just come irradiated well you
know why does food decompose because
there are microbes in it eating it
before you have a chance to get there
right that's why it's not a natural
thing in the universe for something to
decompose that only happens on earth
where there are microbes everywhere
smaller than your eye can see but if you
leave out a slab of meat they'll start
chowing down on it okay so make sure you
take this trip and there's no microbes
on your food so you're radiated so there
you have it all right now there are
other problems the molecular structure
can break down so the meat or whatever
other food can start tasting mealy so
there's not only the taste of the food
but there's texture right so you got if
you want to worry about that all
astronauts take comfort food with them
there is meatloaf okay there's you know
rice and beans there's you know
tortillas tortillas great because it
doesn't make crumbs when you eat it okay
regular bread you eat it makes crumbs in
the crumbs are floating around the space
station could end up in a duct somewhere
okay all right tortilla doesn't make
crumbs so there are a lot of food
International foods at that and
especially evident in the International
Space Station you start comparing food
from different better smelling dinner
for the evening so the point is they do
think about what food to bring anyone
you want enough of a diversity of food
that you can you can spread the spread
the love to different kinds of food
groups and different nationalities but
the bottom line is you don't need more
variation of food than most people would
ever have in their own lives yeah I bet
you there's no more than two or three
kinds of breakfast cereals you ever is
that correct you are correct that's
correct and think about that you know
there's not that many different things
and how many times right eat a pizza and
love it you know at least 20 times a
month practically it is the perfect it
is the perfect food exactly so and I
will still eat me some astronaut ice
cream it's oh by the way the trick there
would take about nine months the
alignment of Earth and Mars that
alignment happens about once every two
and a half years will you minimize the
energy to get there right then when you
launch it takes about nine months but
Earth and Mars are not still lined up
for you to come back you have to wait a
few more years for that that next
alignment to help you come back so a
total roundtrip Mars mission is going to
be three or four years that's you know
what you really want is like Gardens on
Mars you create a habit the Hat module
then and you can grow caves and cows if
you're carnivorous exactly or celery and
carrots if you're veggie and you know go
to town by the way one of my favorite
bands ever Gardens on Mars oh yeah
excellent